do you want to give a special shout out
to Howie Mandel and apologize for not
calling him back
um not really
yeah I thought that was funny whatever
you were supposed to call Harry no he
like I did his podcast and then like it
was just like I ended up walking out
like I was like gonna leave I don't know
if you remember when he you'll see you
pranks me or whatever and then um
podcast and and I pranked you yeah yeah
you pranked me on there and then that
was like the first thing where I was
like
God damn it like I [__] like I was
like I hate highway right now and then
he had me in his podcast and then
Knoxville calls in and does like a
similar like thing and like gets mad at
me for being like yeah and then I like
freaked the [__] out and I was like dude
I'm going I was like I'm out of here I'm
[__] done and I just walked out of
the podcast and then they like coerced
me to come back in and I had to finish
the podcast
and we are on the podcast together so I
sort of had to go back in was Rachel in
on it too no well she like Knoxville
called and said like we didn't get it
clear to a Paramount to go on there and
promote the movie which I didn't
actually even think about being a thing
but Rachel had already done that but I
had not
um and and then they turned it into this
whole like thing like it was like a way
bigger deal than it was so you fell for
the same [__] [__] I pulled on again
yeah yeah it was just another Paramount
thing reloaded no I was not I was I was
sober
do you like shopping on Amazon I do and
good news is Stevo's butt wipes for your
butt hole are available on Amazon and if
you want a real bundle of a deal you can
get Stevo's hot sauce for your butthole
plus Stephen's butthole destroyer and
Stevo's butt wipes for your butthole
it's the butthole bundle available on
Amazon right now
yeah dude